at the start of the movie we are shown a
disturbing image where a woman has
passed away due to an overdose the
photographs surrounding the scene reveal
that she was a single mother raising two
daughters at that very moment her
youngest daughter Rose arrives at the
door and is taken aback the scene then
transitions to the present day where
Rose has become a therapist at a mental
hospital currently she is attending to a
manic patient named Carl who repeatedly
says that he is going to die Rose makes
efforts to console him but Carl keeps on
murmuring so she hasn't admitted for a
few days after completing her work Rose
gets ready to depart but right then she
is assigned another case involving a
patient named Laura Rose reluctantly
meets her and learns that the poor girl
is suffering from bouts of depression
after she witnessed her professor commit
the unthinkable Rose claims that it is
normal to be paranoid when someone dies
but Laura asserts that she is not crazy
in reality she is acting strange because
a creepy entity with a weird smile is
following her everywhere she goes The
Entity form of random people and says
you are going to die soon after Laura
suddenly collapses to the floor and
begins to scream as if she has seen
something sensing the degrading
situation Rose swiftly calls for
assistance and she makes the call and
turns back around she is shocked to see
Laura standing upright appearing calm
and wearing a haunting smile
unfortunately before help arrives Laura
Takes A Shard of broken pottery that
commits the unthinkable leaving Rose
horrified I really recommend watching
that scene it's unbelievably well edited
following this tragic incident two
detectives arrive at the hospital one of
whom happens to be Joel Rose's former
boyfriend they ask her several questions
but she is too terrified to speak Rose
only reveals that Laura had a creepy
smile on her face when she committed the
unthinkable after the formalities are
over Rose finally returns home in order
to relax she takes a shower and is about
to pour herself a drink when she notices
a scary sight of Laura standing in the
corner at the same time her fiance
Trevor enters the room startling her
momentarily he notices her all worried
and inquires if everything is all right
Trevor will be our token jackass who
never believes the protagonist in
response Rose nods her head and changes
the topic swiftly later that night the
cup Apple joins Rose's sister Holly and
her husband for a dinner outing all of
them talk about their respective work
lives but Rose appears to be distracted
she keeps remembering the harrowing
scene of Laura's demise the next day
Rose decides to return to work but she
struggles to move on from the previous
incidents intrigued she approaches the
receptionist and requests to see the
report on Gabriel the professor who
committed the unthinkable in front of
Laura while reviewing the report Rose
receives a call from Holly who extends
an invitation to her son's birthday
celebration as they talk on the phone
Rose glances at the window and notices a
figure in the distance that resembles
Laura however she dismisses it as her
imagination and proceeds to check on her
patients when she passes by Carl's room
she shockingly notices him with the same
disturbing Smile as Laura had all of a
sudden he begins shouting at her
declaring that she's going to die this
terrifies Rose so she urgently calls for
nurses to restrain him however in a
dramatic turn of events it is revealed
that Carl has been asleep the whole time
everything that happened earlier was
only imagination when the supervisor of
the hospital Mr Desai learns of this he
becomes concerned for Rose's mental
state and advises her to take a week off
later that night Rose is alone at home
when the house alarm suddenly starts
beeping causing her to panic she
cautiously heads towards the front door
with a pair of scissors in hand but
realizes that it's locked Upon returning
to the living room she discovers that
the back door is open in that unsettling
moment Rose receives a call from a
security operator who weirdly tells her
to look behind her but to make things
more confusing the phone rings again
revealing that the previous call was
merely a hallucination Rose quickly
answers it and to her relief it is a
genuine security operator on the other
end in no time several police officers
arrive at her house to investigate but
they find no signs of intrusion Trevor
also reaches the scene and Wordly asks
Rose if she's fine with a confused face
she says yes but there is still one
problem she can't seem to find her pet
cat mustache anywhere over the course of
the next few days Rose continues to
experience hallucinations leading people
to view her as mentally unstable
concerned about her own well-being she
seeks help from her former therapist Dr
Madeline northcott Rose tells her
everything including Laura the creepy
smiles and even her missing pet cat she
frantically says that she is becoming
paranoid more and more every day hearing
all of this Dr Madeline theorizes that
she's still suffering from the traumatic
death of her abusive and mentally ill
mother on the weekend Rose attends her
nephew's birthday party even though she
hasn't been feeling well at all things
go well for the first few minutes and
Rose assumes that she's got rid of her
hallucinations but then her nephew opens
the gift she brought for him and inside
is the lifeless body of her missing cat
mustache the shocking Nation sends Rose
into tears as she desperately tries to
convince everyone that she didn't do it
in the midst of this she notices one of
the party guests smiling at her creepily
this startles Rose horribly and she ends
up breaking a glass table and injuring
herself in the next scene Trevor brings
her home after a short trip to the
hospital before getting out of the car
Rose attempts to confide in him about
the entity that's haunting her but
Trevor speculates that she may have
inherited her mother's mental illness he
just keeps on douching it up later Rose
continues her research on Gabriel until
she hears her mother's voice calling out
to her from the darkness determined to
ignore it she tries to go to bed but a
figure resembling her mother appears
behind her in the morning Rose sets out
to Gabriel's residence to gather more
details about his death upon arrival she
is welcomed by his wife Victoria who
discloses that the professor had also
witnessed a self-kill before committing
the unthinkable she then leads Rose to a
room where several sketches made by
Gabriel are on display all of them have
the same creepy smile on their faces
after learning all of this rose asserts
that Gabriel wasn't insane and that the
experiences he had were real she claims
that she is also going through similar
occurrences unfortunately this only
angers Victoria that she believes Rose
is trying to make fun of her late
husband so she kicks her out of the
house now with no options left Rose
approaches her ex-boyfriend Joel and
requests a favor to investigate cases
related to Gabriel the detective is a
bit hesitant but he agrees to do it for
the sake of their past relationship Joel
then accesses reports on his laptop and
discovers that the professor had
witnessed a woman named Angela
committing the unthinkable he then
conducts a similar research on that
woman and coincidentally finds that she
had also witnessed a self-inflicted
death when they view the recorded
footage they see a man smiling before
committing the unthinkable in front of
Angela following this Rose returns home
with the intention of revealing
everything to her fiance however her
plans are disrupted when she discovers
that Trevor has brought Dr Madeline to
check on her he believes that she is gun
mental this enrages Rose and she accuses
Trevor of abandoning her during her time
of need she then storms off and goes to
Holly's Place hoping to get some support
from her Rose eagerly shows her sister
the printed images of the other victims
explaining how she got her patient's
curse however Holly dismisses the notion
of curses and compares her to her late
mother this triggers a wave of anger
within Ross who has reached her breaking
point of being constantly pushed around
by everyone as a result she chastises
her sister calling herself-centered and
egotistical Rose then returns to her car
and tries to calm herself down suddenly
Holly comes out of the house and Taps on
the car window when Rose looks outside
her sister's face inexplicably Falls
upside down did I get you narration jump
scare but in reality she is once again
hallucinating later that evening Rose is
at a restaurant trying to keep herself
busy when she receives a sudden call
from Joel he says that he researched the
creepy Smiles all night and learned
something shocking altogether there are
20 cases and out of them 19 are
self-kills with similar patterns how
however in the 20th case a man named
Robert disrupted the pattern by
committing murder when a random guy
witnessed the incident he committed the
unthinkable thereby continuing the
pattern intrigued by the Survivor Rose
decides to meet him face to face shortly
after she arrives at the prison where
Robert is held Rose approaches him and
pretends to have a patient experiencing
a similar ordeal in response Robert
explains that the entity feeds on trauma
and the only means of Escape is to
commit a brutal Act of murder in front
of a witness thereby traumatizing them
hearing this Rose becomes angry and
vehemently shouts I cannot kill anyone
she inadvertently reveals here that she
has been cursed by The Entity as a
result Robert starts panicking so the
guards quickly arrive and take
later when Rose reaches home Dr Madeline
unexpectedly pays her visit the two
engage in a conversation which is soon
interrupted by a phone call Rose
reluctantly answers only to discover
that the caller is none other than Dr
Madeline herself this means that the
person next to her is the entity just
then the entity starts to smile and
utters the words time is running out in
the next scene we see Rose driving to
the hospital armed with a knife she goes
straight to the patient Carl's room and
confronts him just then Mr Desai walks
in a cautioning rose that she shouldn't
be around the patients he also tries to
inquire if she's doing well these days
but ignoring all of this Rose suddenly
brings out her knife and repeatedly
stabs Carl it appears as if she wants to
pass on the curse by murdering the poor
man however despite several stabs to the
abdomen Carl continues to smile at her
he feels no pain at all the next second
Rose awakens in her car realizing that
the entire sequence was another
hallucination shortly after Morgan
approaches her vehicle and is why she's
there but she hastily speeds away
without providing an explanation
noticing the presence of a knife in
Rose's car Morgan promptly contacts Joel
alerting him to the situation afterwards
Rose drives to her abandoned childhood
home as it is the only place that she
can be away from people Rose fears that
she will end up hurting someone so she
wants to isolate herself from the rest
of the world upon arrival at the house
Rose hears a strange noise and when she
goes to investigate she finds the entity
of her mother but our brave protagonist
is not scared anymore she confronts The
Entity asking her to stop bothering her
at once following this the movie goes
into a flashback to the day where Rose's
mother had passed away in a shocking
turn of events it is revealed that the
woman was alive when Rose found her
however the little girl didn't call for
help as she hated her abusive mom and
wanted her to die back at present The
Entity takes up another form revealing a
tall scary figure it swiftly attacks
Rose and pins her to the ground claiming
that it will forever torment her mind
however Rose summons her inner strength
and manages to break free by striking
the entity with a lamp causing it to
catch fire she then leaves the house
symbolically letting go of her trauma
after the harrowing ordeal Rose drives
back to Joel's house hoping that he will
let her spend the night the latter
agrees and assures her of his comfort
but as he speaks a creepy smile forms on
base alarmed Rose hastily exits the
house only to find herself still outside
her old house this reveals that her
previous experience was a complete
hallucination shortly after the real
Joel calls her name causing panic to
Surge through her she rushes back inside
barricading herself in the house so that
Joel cannot have the curse passed to him
right then the entity rips off its skin
to reveal its true form this sight
causes Rose to have a nervous breakdown
descending into a state of
trauma-induced paralysis then in a
horrifying sight The Entity forces
itself inside her body through her mouth
in the final scene Joel manages to break
through the front door only to witness
Rose setting herself on fire with his
smile on her face effectively passing
the curse onto him subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching